bonjour j'ai ambages faire merci de
répondre à nos questions le texte arrive
donc au sénat après avoir été votée en
décembre à l'assemblée nationale 350
amendements sont à compter quelle va
être la teneur des débats entre
sénateurs à partir d'aujourd'hui où le
je suppose non non je ne crois pas que
ce soit ou le ce n'est pas j'avais
l'habitude du sénat d'avoir des débats
houleux mais plutôt un débat qui va
faire le partage effectivement entre les
libertés publiques qui est un des
piliers de du sénat nous sommes des
grands défenseurs de la ligue des
libertés publiques on l'a vu notamment
au moment des cris de la crise du coc
vide qu'on vit toujours
on nous sommes toujours très réticents à
donner beaucoup de pouvoirs à l'exécutif
donc on fait très attention à ses
libertés publiques
et puis tout de même des sujets
d'efficacité pour les forces de l'ordre
on ne peut pas dire que depuis plusieurs
mois plusieurs années les forces de
l'anp n'ont pas été menacés et quel le
que la population ne se plaint pas que
la police parfois est inefficace
il ya de nouveaux outils il faut les
encadrer donc nous essayons de trouver
ce chemin de crête entre libertés
publiques et efficacité de la police
pour la paix général s'est dit on avait
les policiers rend les gardiens de la
paix et bien c'est ça que vous retrouver
la paix et la liberté
vous parlez de chemin de crête
c'est-à-dire coincer un jeu
d'équilibriste c'est ça entre trop ou
pas assez on parle notamment de
l'article 24 qui pénalise
diffusion de l'image du visage ou tout
autre élément d'identification d'un
policier ou d'un gendarme en
intervention c'est a mis le feu aux
poudres
votre camp politique les républicains
appellent plus à serrer la vis les
syndicats de journalistes estiment que
le texte est liberticide vous le
comprenez quand même ou est-ce qu'il
faut placer le curseur justement parlé
de cette ligne de crête
un consensus est ce que c'est possible
on parle d'une provocation à
l'identification ça veut dire quoi
oui alors tout d'abord le vous faites
assez précis le texte elle qui écrit par
l'assemblée nationale remettent en cause
la liberté de la presse car touché cette
loi est essentielle qu'est la liberté de
la presse et la liberté de la presse ça
fait partie des libertés publiques
donc nous y sommes attachés simplement
il ne veut pas vous avoir échappé que de
nombreux policiers ont été menacés
certains assassiné par des voyous par
des terroristes par des assassins qui
grâce à des images grâce à la diffusion
et c'est aussi le cas pour samuel pâtit
eh bien il des appels à la haine sur les
réseaux qui menacent leur intégrité
personnelle et non pas leur fonction
donc il faut trouver l'allier le
contrôle de la fonction policière est
détaché cela de l'identification
personnelle pour pour les libertés
publiques
après cette injustice de le faire et la
justice doit avoir accès à tous toutes
les images toutes les données mais pas
le tout à chacun et on va se venger chez
les gens
ça c'est absolument odieux ce n'est pas
la liberté c'est la dictature la
dictature de la menace du terrorisme de
ceux qui utilisent la peur en permanence
alors je ne suis pas d'accord avec
l'amalgamme scandaleux fait par le
journaliste l'apprenti journaliste
précédent de la cgt qui parlait d' état
policier mais non on ne saisit pas
d'état policier
il s'agit bien évidemment de laisser la
liberté de la presse mais de ne pas
condamner systématiquement les forces de
l'ordre avant que l'interview sont
intervenus c'est sans doute
le chemin de crête que nous cherchons et
nous ne sommes pas dans les propos
extrémistes et nous ferons très
attention à cela les organisations de
défense des libertés les syndicats de
journalistes juste ce texte liberticide
en cause a également l'utilisation des
drones par la police qui ne protégerait
pas assez les droits des individus
est ce que vous comprenez qu'une police
qui surveille trop puisse faire peur non
mais moi je vous dit autre chose
est ce que vous comprenez que des
policiers on le retire ce des parties
d'artifice sur eux et qu'on ne puisse
pas parce que les caméras de la ville
sont détruites aussi immédiatement par
les dealers et cetera qu' on puisse pas
regarder observer ces sont des moyens
d'intervention utile lors de certaines
manifestations il faut les encadrer
c'est ce que nous proposons dans ce
texte c'est pas le drone à tout va c'est
pas je survole et je regarde ce qui se
passe chez vous pour vous contrôler
c'est dans des cas parfaitement encadrée
par la loi c'est à dire par la volonté
du peuple représenté par les
parlementaires
eh bien on encadre ces pratiques voilà
ce que nous voulons aujourd'hui donc
parallèlement à cet examen de cette
proposition de loi
du côté du palais du luxembourg il ya
donc une une manifestation d'opposants à
ce texte
à quoi est-ce que vous vous attendez
pour cet après midi est ce que vous
craignez par exemple des débordements
dans le scénar est un événement protéger
de la république très dignement et sait
très bien que l'on puisse en france
justement manifester et avoir sa liberté
d'opinion et c'est extrêmement important
je me battrai toujours pour la liberté
de manifester c'est dans la constitution
mais je me battrai toujours pour que le
parlement est notamment au sénat puisse
délibérer dans le calme et la sérénité
des français valent mieux que de tout
tout tout des agissements souvent
médiatique
merci j'ai embauché d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
sénateur les républicains du département
de l'oise